den vergangenen wochen war ich in der
ukraine unterwegs als reporter ich fahr
dahin schon seit 20 13 eigentlich als
damals ja menschen mit der europäischen
flagge demonstriert haben für freiheit
frieden und sie sehen wladimir putin das
ist der mann der möglicherweise mit
seinen truppen wieder in die ukraine
reinmarschieren will man sieht einen
riesigen kanzler auflauf an der grenze
man sieht dort menschen die große angst
haben ich habe eine frau getroffen die
gesagt hat sich will sich jetzt selbst
verteidigen sie macht kurse dort um wenn
wladimir putin wladimir putins truppen
einmarschieren wenn sie nach kiew kommen
sich verteidigen zu können ich finde es
ist eine schande wie sich deutschland
verhält ich finde es eine schande dass
sich eine verteidigungsministerin
ernsthaft hinstellt und sagt hier sind
5000 helme herzlichen glückwunsch und
karine ja bitte wie soll man sich denn
da verteidigen gegen wladimir putins
armee und dass diese
verteidigungsministerin nicht mal
kapiert dass sie keine ahnung offenbar
hat von außen und defensiv politik
verteidigungspolitik dann muss ich
wirklich sagen ist sie eine
fehlbesetzung unabhängig davon
sanktioniert endlich premier putin und
nicht nur wladimir putin sondern auch
all diejenigen die ihn unterstützt haben
in den vergangenen monaten in den
vergangenen jahren dazu gehört auch
altkanzler gerhard schröder ich fordere
sanktionen gegen gerhard schröder er ist
jemand der entscheidend dazu beigetragen
hat und dass wladimir putin so weit hoch
kommen konnte dass er überhaupt ein nord
stream projekt durchdrücken konnte ich
finde all diejenigen die putin weiterhin
unterstützen gehören sanktioniert also
lieber paul ronzheimer ich schätze dich
ungeheuer weil du nicht nur in schützen
haben in der ukraine eine tolle rolle
spielt sondern auch in der innenpolitik
sehr gut auskennt
sanktionen gegen schröder zu verlangen
ist eine kuriose forderung schröder wenn
man beobachtet was er erklärt hat in den
letzten jahren hat kein wort zu putin
gesagt keine frage beantwortet er gibt
nur noch ganz selten interviews wenn er
ganz sicher ist ja auch bei instagram
beschäftigung mit einer ehefrau moment
moment mit allen möglichen aber jeden
oder seien ursachen er hat sich auch
nicht georderte nord stream er hat sich
auch nicht geäußert zu dem aufmarsch
geht nicht darum was er sich wie er sich
äußert sondern was er tut und das wir
heben
da hat nur ausreden da zieht auch keine
fehler sondern er sitzt in den
aufsichtsgremien von gazprom und rosneft
gazprom mafia unternehmen liefert gas
jaja team von denen leben wir und
rosneft liefert benzin und zwar den
größten teil des deutschen
benzinverbrauchs der kommt aus russland
damit fahren wir autos und mit dem gas
heizen wir unsere häuser und da hätte
schon längst alternativen finden müssen
und für das wir das benzin aus russland
hat man eine weile gebraucht aber
jedenfalls hat er sich da hat sich ja
niemand beklagt darüber dass wir
russisches benzin fahren sondern und
dafür das ist seine aufgabe und dafür
wollen wir ihn bestrafen er redet nicht
für putin er redet für die energie
geredet ausschließlich für putin aber
meine frage an wolfgang kubicki was
sollten wir denn tun sind sie zufrieden
herr rony sich will sich einfach weil
ich faul lambrecht dort ich gestellt hat
und 5000 helfer verteilt als hätte ich
nicht gemacht weil das projekt peinlich
wirkt ich hätte auch keine feldlazarett
hingeschickt das werde nicht mehr selbst
in schicken sondern ankauf sieht man
dass auch peinlich was sie da gemacht
hat ja ich hätte komplett darauf
verzichtet und erklärt wir liefern wir
liefern keine waffen in uk ich fand
keine waffen in spannungsgebiete es die
ständige redewendung und beschlusslage
seitdem ich politisch denken kann dieser
32 jahren parlamenten das war bisher
immer so dass wir uns zu verhalten haben
und ich bin auch nicht davon überzeugt
dass waffen nicht an den koreaner den
frieden stabilisieren aber nicht
vielleicht das risiko erhöhen weil zu
glauben dass die hausfrau in kiew sich
gegen russische truppen verteidigen kann
wenn sie den einmarschieren ist sowas
von naiv dass ich ihnen das gar nicht
zutrauen ich weiß nicht was ich dort in
brasilien kubicki werke dort die
stimmung ja in der ukraine und wieviel
erschütterung über positionen
deutschlands wie von ihnen dort nämlich
raus kommt wo man sagt wie kann
deutschland sich eigentlich so verhalten
ja weil wie gesagt wir dann nach wie vor
davon ausgehen dass das waffenlieferung
krisengebiete mit unserem
selbstverständnis nicht viel vereinbar
sind und noch einmal ich werde mich auch
dagegen zu sagen putin ist jetzt der
ganz bösen aldi in der nähe von putin
sind eine ganz böse das mag so sein aber
er hat ja bloß hunderte menschen in
syrien abgeschlachtet hat truppen in die
ukraine geschickt hat hier wenige
kilometer entfernt im tiergarten leute
umbringen lassen hat herr navalny
vergiftet
gut das war da alles persönlich und ihre
unsere amerikanischen freunde in
afghanistan auch nur stützende maßnahmen
ich will das gar nicht vergleichen aber
sie sind gerade dabei etwas böses zu
initialisieren ohne dass sie die
möglichkeit haben gesprächsebene zu
eröffnen und konflikte zu sage ja nicht
dass man nicht sprechen soll er also da
muss ich schon sagen ich finde so dieses
argument es ist schon ein bisschen
leicht zu sagen wir liefern keine waffen
in spannungsgebiete so ungefähr als sei
die ukraine irgend beliebiges land wir
haben hier eine klare frage auch des
verhältnisses von russland zum
völkerrecht und des verhältnisses von
russlands zur nato und da kann ich nur
sagen das war eine peinliche nummer mit
den 5000 helm und deswegen finde ich
sowieso mehr eigentlich frappierend ich
nur das lasse mit balanciert diskutieren
weil ich freue mich jetzt wieder zurück
fragen sind sie für waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine und dann welche waffen also
ich finde jedenfalls wir sollten diesen
pauschal ausschluss nicht machen und wir
sollten grundlegend darüber diskutieren
als diese 5000 helm und wir müssen schon
robusten zu haben ich möchte an die
ukraine wir müssen da aus meiner sicht
eine robuste politik jedenfalls an den
tag legen und ich finde da ist führung
auch der bundesregierung gefragt warum
sie schon wieder aufregung natürlich ist
das gefragt ich finde es ja geradezu
absurd dass es dann heißt ja wir gucken
da einfach mal ein bisschen aber sie hat
doch nicht richtig sein doch
parlamentarier darüber auch entscheiden
so meine frage ist wollen sie waffen im
quali liefern welche waffen also die
frauen wären sie im zweifel bereit dann
auch deutsche truppen in der ukraine zu
stationiert für den fall dass es nicht
ausreicht hier noch nie hatten keine und
das ist völlig klar wir werden daher
keine isolierten aktionen machen sondern
das muss man im zusammenhang mit unseren
bündnispartnern diskutieren und ich
finde vor allem wir müssen hier dann von
der regierung die hat da auch im übrigen
das initiativrecht ja an vielen stellen
in der auswärtigen politik dann müssten
wir jetzt mal vorschläge haben olaf
scholz duckt sich weg der hat im
parlament heute die chance verstreichen
der vorschlag war ja wir liefern keine
waffen es ist der vorschlag wir liefern
können wäre das ein bisschen wenig oder
also ich also aus der perspektive der
ukraine ist es doch ziemlich ziemlich
wenig wenn man sagt hier sind die 5000
helm und jetzt ist erstmal schluss mehr
haben wir euch nicht es gibt es gibt
leider darf ist zu recht zu kritisieren
länder muss man mehr erwarten von
resultierte länder wir haben eine andere
geschichte mit russland oder so der
sowjetunion als deutschland das dürfen
wir nie vergessen
erstens zweitens reden wir hier über
sanktionen gegen schröder wie sollen die
denn aussehen
konsumenten schröder
in der werbepause hinterher haben
hier sollen aussehen dass er unter
hausarrest gestellt wird dass ihm das
helmut baur und sauber sein das handy
abgenommen heerstraße beschlagnahmt wird
das eher harburger haft geht bis er sich
von putin distanziert hat glaube ich
finde die sanktionen gegen einen
deutschen staat nein nein heute
angesetzte gegenüber putin als jetzt die
sanktionen gegenüber geheimnis dahinter
regierung verfügen dass jemand der für
wladimir putin arbeitet und so ein
nahestehender lobbyist ist
möglicherweise ein konto eingefroren
wird ja da bin ich dafür ja wo denn das
frieren wir jetzt das sammelkonto auch
an die ukraine führt
auch nicht es gibt ja schon unterschied
zwischen sozusagen einem staat oder
andere ihr leben in einem demokratischen
rechtsstaat sie können eine politische
meinung kamen aber zu glauben sie können
einem deutschen staatsbürger bei ihm
seine meinung nicht fasst mit konnten
ein freestyler und nicht die meinung
nicht die meinung sondern ich meine als
lobbyist auftritt für wladimir putin das
tut er ja nicht doch nein er hat seit
jahren kein wort mehr zu putin gesagt
weil er einmal einen satz gesagt hat
lupenreiner demokrat der bitter bereut
hat seit diesem satz hat der ist ja eher
mehreren aufsichtsrat der demian ja aber
da geht es ja um unsere
energieversorgung und natürlich davon
also zusatzfunktionen senders ist das
ganz russland oder putin besteht und er
für alles verantwortlich ist für mich
auch ein bisschen komisch das wäre so
als wenn wir sagen so eine olaf scholz
will in deutschland für alles was hier
passiert ist also war es heute als
rechtsanwalt in den sitzungen finden
nach acht herzlichen dank für diese
hitzigen diskussion heute abend danke